hello everyone welcome to cloud honor
these are live webinars put on every
Tuesday by Google cloud platform
my name is Chad Jennings and I'm a
product manager for bigquery to add my
name is Soleil Kelly I'm a product
marketer on the data analytics team here
at Google cloud and today we're gonna be
talking about geospatial analysis and
bigquery and particularly doing that
with bigquery GIS do note you can ask
questions at any time on the platform we
have Googlers on standby to answer your
questions so our goal today is really a
couple fold we want to introduce you to
the bigquery GIS service if you're not
yet familiar with that and beed get you
up and running so you can add GIS into
your toolbox as an analyst let's jump
right in
so spatial context really matters from
our perspective Maps provide this really
unique type of context and when we think
of context think of the who what when
where why isn't house in particular that
that where when you add your data and
you put it on a map it just instantly
becomes real becomes relatable as a
human and that's really powerful to help
you make better business decisions it
second of all gives you this rich extra
set of data at your disposal and there's
there's a nice benefit there because
when you put your data on that map and
you join with other things you instantly
have context in physical space right
those Maps connect that physical space
to that various sometimes intangible
space of data analysis on a computer
connected to the cloud right
and so yes Maps really matter from from
the human perspective and also from the
business perspective so take for example
you know this map in Denver I might be a
retailer in this particular location in
Denver and I would want to analyze where
my customers are or the different
different demographics from from
different neighborhoods in the Denver
area and maybe I'm considering opening
up a new store in a different
neighborhood I would also want to factor
in you know other competitors in that in
the area and and think about different
physical geographies that are present in
the space as well and when I actually
overlay my demographic analysis on top
of the map as opposed to just looking at
tables of data I instantly just have
more
texts I can see where the freeways are
that might be gridlocked during the time
I want my customers to come to my store
I can see physical geographic boundaries
like bodies of water or mountain ranges
and and and things of this nature so
really useful to be able to
contextualize your data in the car and
in maps for sure now if you have just a
small set of data you can you can
imagine almost doing this analysis by
hand if you had just a few hundred
customers and they're all coming from a
certain neighborhood easy enough but in
our age of information and the the
accessibility we have to just buku data
from all the open datasets with you know
from weather to census data and other
sources you can really go you know
pretty wild from an from an analytics
perspective thinking about all the fun
things you can do with space and for
that you know you might be thinking
about if you had millions of customers
let's just hypothetically say you wanted
to join that with some of those bigger
bigger data sets you might need a little
bit more horsepower to actually conduct
that GIS analysis and and for this we're
we're incredibly excited to have
launched bit crazy is into beta a few
weeks back here in September and really
what this means for for analysts
especially those that are already using
bigquery is that hey we're bringing the
GIS functionality right directly into
the data warehouse you no longer would
need to export your data elsewhere and
bring it into a purpose-built GIS
application right all that core
functionality is right there on top of
your data and accessible right there and
and what's really unique and different
about this service is you know combining
this cloud GIS functionality with the
the raw power of bigquery and it's
massively parallel processing or MVP
architecture to do big data to kind of
merge big data and GIS in the cloud and
that's that's super exciting we're
really excited to bring that to market
and Chad being product manager for
bigquery it's gonna dive into a little
more details on this so yeah and I just
wanted to say though that you know that
intersection of big data and GIS is a
thing that we're really excited to
address in the marketplace so you know
with the launch of this bigquery is the
only cloud MPP enterprise data warehouse
to support GIS data types and functions
as first-class citizens and so we're
really proud of that and the engineering
team has worked on this actually in
conjunction with the earth engine team
so we use the same computational
libraries on
the covers that power things like Google
Maps Earth engine Google Earth so it's
really bringing a lot of really awesome
Google assets you know to our customers
which is fun circle all right but first
off you may have a question what is this
bigquery thing anyway let's start there
so bigquery is Google clouds enterprise
data warehouse so you interact with it
in sequel and it is serverless and fully
managed and what that means is you don't
have to mess with spinning up nodes or
spinning up clusters we handle all of
that for you and so what that means is
you bring your data you bring your
workloads you load them both you press
the button that says run query and we
spin up all the computer resources and
storage resources that you need
that's what fully managed means to us
this this product scans goes super big
and super fast our largest customers
have hundreds of petabytes of storage
with us you know and our largest queries
and you know regularly exceed 20 or 30
billion rows so Big Data G is together
right there's that intangible data
analytics thing and oh yeah think again
really what is thirty trillion actually
mean so here's what bigquery G is
actually means right we're supporting
Jia Jia graphic data types Geographic
functions and we're gonna go through
these in some detail in just a second
here and then like kind of where the
payoff happens is we're also launching
something called or we have launched
something called bigquery geo vis which
is a lightweight visualization tool to
put all of those cool data that you just
figured out onto a map alright so a
little context setting why bother
Euclid would look at this map and go
that's perfectly fine right that is a
straight line between two points
shortest distance that's how she you
should go except as we all know now
right
Euclid didn't know this but we do curved
earth the shortest distance between
these particular two points Seattle and
stood guard anyone curious is a great
circle route and you know to be honest
even though I come from a navigation
background I I never really quite got
what a straight circle route truly meant
until I looked at it
visualized on Google Earth from space
so Euclid was right straight distant a
straight line between two points that is
the right way to go if you want to get
there fast and that is what a straight
line looks like on the curved space so
with geographic data types and functions
we want to honor the curvature of the
earth right seems like a big thing to
honor and actually do these calculations
exactly right
so these are the data types that we're
supporting supporting so pointing
supporting point line string polygons
all the way down to collections so it's
quite a rich data set all right and now
so they'll take us away with the
functions yeah for sure so we are you
know we love our sequel verbs and we've
just brought in about 40 new new verbs
into the bigquery as first-class
citizens again and it conformed to the
post GIS project spatial type function
convention the st underscore and we have
a number of different functions here you
can see in the table on the right if you
are familiar with post GIS this will be
a walk in the park and you can maybe
grab a super quick glass of water or
something but if you're just getting
started and want to just know at a high
level what these functions are all about
and the kind of the things that you can
do on your geospatial data we're just
gonna dive into that super quick
constructors as the name suggests these
are really about building net new
geographies from existing coordinates
they'll say a lot long pair or existing
geographies like a couple of polygons or
aligns and making a collection so the
diagram here demonstrates you know a set
of five different lat/long pairs and
you're making a line out of those right
parsers in formatters I mean obviously
we want some interoperability between
different formats and so these are all
about creating or exporting to
geographies in two different formats so
from binary to a to a polygon from geo
JSON to to text and things like this
these are the the functions that you
would use to do that so that you have a
little bit more interact with other with
other programs transformations again so
these are creating new geographies
similar to constructors but they're
having the similar properties as their
input geographies so here in the diagram
we've highlighted the centroid function
so if you wanted to find the center of
some sort of zip code polygons you'd use
that function to create a point a lat
long set out of that
existing geography and many other types
of transformations naturally as well
predicates so great for filtering you
know is this region are the data within
this region existing within another
region in this particular zip code or
something you know yes or no or
true/false questions rather so great for
filtering your Geographic data and and
whatnot accessor so sometimes you just
need to know a little bit of the the
metadata about you geography data and so
for this we will we have a number of
functions here look how many vertices
are how many points are there as part of
this polygon so you can ask those types
of questions
is it a point is it a line as a polygon
if you just get a whole bunch of
Geographic data you can ask those types
of questions there measures as the name
suggests pretty pretty intuitive but
what's the perimeter what's the area
distances between points etc these are
real core functionality not flashy but
important no no no here's the flash
super super important I mean these are
that like when you immediately think
about GIS data at least for me you're
asking those questions like wait what's
the distance between X am i and you know
these are questions you often have them
but yeah joins are so this is where the
real magic starts and doing joins on
geographic data sets the in the demos
that we'll talk about in a second we
actually join on zip code but we're
actually joining on the zip code integer
right with these functions you can
actually or sorry the the integer that
measure or that identifies the zip code
with these you can actually do joins on
the geography like you know you know
find all the points that are in these
two datasets join them together with any
of these predicates so this this is like
the this is where the magic really
happens here okay but in terms of like
eye candy
this is the magic so this is bigquery
geo viz and you can see from the gif
here that you can you know compose a
query run a query and then style the
results in a map all interactively it's
a lightweight tool so this isn't going
to handle you know millions upon
millions you know it's it's limited to
about 2000 2000 points but it solves the
use case of I'm an analyst I wrote a
query please let me see that on a map
just to make sure that like I'm sane or
that I got the results that I expected
great for ad-hoc exploration yeah
exactly and if you got more serious
mapping needs you can export a table
from big
into GCSE and then import that into
Earth engine and here you use JavaScript
you can create maps of like arbitrary
complexity and like arbitrary beautiful
this sad word it should be there it is
okay okay so we'll dive into a couple a
couple demos here and so referencing the
example that Soleil talked about earlier
we're gonna pretend that we are retail
site selectors and so we have a store
and so they the demographic the target
demographic of your store is 25 to 34
how about 25 to 44 since 44 yeah since
that's what I prepped yeah let's do that
one okay alright so cured let's let's
cut over let's cut over to the demo and
so what are we looking at yeah yeah so
this is the bigquery web UI and what we
see here is on the rule on the Left
panel here there are a bunch of like
basically asset navigators right you can
look at your queries you can look at
save queries the job history that you've
run in this project you can even look at
data sets down here I'll double click
into the bigquery public data and
there's no a whole bunch of stuff
baseball data sets pretty fun we're not
going to do that one today
sorry but unless my customers are
baseball looks right right now it's a
retail shock in any case the Left panel
here to navigate assets the this window
right here is the query composer window
so this is where you write your sequel
and then you get your results back down
here in the lower pane and so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to walk you
through this query real quick so one
thing that I like to do a lot in sequel
is use these with statements to pull
parameters up to the top of a query just
means that if you want to share that
query with somebody or if you want to
you know adjust a parameter you don't
have to go searching through lines and
lines and lines of sequel to get to it
so we're gonna set parameters we're
gonna pick latitude and longitude right
that's the center of Seattle so we'll
pretend we're gonna put a store there
you could get this very simply by like
you know just googling center of Seattle
or googling an address and we'll return
you the lat/long and then we're going to
stipulate for this one we're going to
stipulate the radius as one
and then this set of code pulls all the
zip codes within that area so it uses
this STD within so it creates a point
from the latitude and longitude and then
make short and then it looks at the the
zip area latitude and longitude and
finds all of the zip codes that are
sixteen hundred and nine meters or
within sixteen hundred and nine metres
happens to be one way one mile that's
right thank you
the next set of this code is where we're
going to pull the stats and so this
table that we're looking at is actually
available in public data set inside of
bigquery it's called no surprise
population by zip twenty ten and so what
this code is doing is simply adding up
the population totals from these
different demographic buckets this data
set only has age and gender you know if
you look at the u.s. census page or the
American Community Survey the
fact-finder page is really useful for
this you know they have many many many
more demographic buckets but we'll focus
on these and then at the end we're just
going to pick all of those zip codes the
CICC code stats and the zip code
geometries and we're gonna pull them out
into a single table and so run the query
and it was cached right the point oh one
seven is they use the cash I prep this
ahead of time because I didn't want to I
didn't want to burden you all with
watching the curry run but what you can
see here is this table so here's nine
eight one five four this is actually a
tiny little zip code that's just the
purposes of the US Post Office so no
people live in it
but you can see you know these are the
populations and then here's the polygon
and that polygon string is totally
parsable by human readers and you look
at that you're like Oh minus one twenty
two point three three three five six
four yeah that's downtown Seattle right
right no nobody does that so what we
really want to do is we want to see that
on a map so let's walk through how big
crazy Oguz works so I've actually
pre-populated this one as well and you
can see that I've increased the radius
to 15 miles it's
see the same query so I've copied from
the composer window and pasted into the
bigquery geo of his window and run the
results to get this map over here and
what's cool about this tool is that you
can style interactively so the fill
color for this chloroplast I have chosen
to be population of 65 plus but if I
wanted to change that I could in real
time as a matter of fact we're gonna
dive in to the North End of Seattle here
you know what that's a little bit opaque
for my taste I'm going to lighten the
fill opacity we're gonna make it 0.5
there that lightens it up a little bit
it's a little easier to see go back to
fill color and we're gonna look at a
couple different demographics so
demographic number one there's my 25 to
44 thank you right on so let's see where
your target demographic is we'll change
the range a little bit since there yeah
the max is 21 yeah 21,000 that guy yep
and so what you see is if we zero in on
this zip code so 9 8 103 you know
there's a concentration here and there's
a dearth of your target demographic in 9
8 1 9 so like don't put your store come
put your store out there but what I
wanted to point out here was let's go
ahead and have a look at well let's
let's expand it let's say you were
looking for college-age students and
then this zip code here lights up what's
there there happens to be University
there right and we haven't even changed
the range but you can see it's actually
similar similar range set there but but
all right yeah I got very high
concentration there if so like no
surprise the University of Washington
lights up and then if we look at the
sixty five-plus and I adjust the range
here to 7000 you can see that the you
can see the populations are starting to
move
not just north but out right so this is
now flight from the urban center I
suppose and like folks folks in this
demographic are moving away from the
city center okay so what we've shown
here is the ability to do geospatial
analysis and then style a map and
visualize and map in real time if you
wanted to share this with folks right
you
take a screenshot or share the query you
can even make that nice big oh yeah so
it's alright we can zoom out and see the
entire the entire extent yep okay okay
so geospatial information is useful
partly because it's not focused in any
one particular area so I ran this query
again for New York and so again this is
the 0 to 24 demographic and if we just
click over to this other tab here you
can see that and sorry this one let's
see and the styling this one is the 65
plus I'll switch back and forth between
these tabs you can see that the these
neighborhoods out here in the south of
in the south of New York get quite a bit
darker so what that means is like you
know folks our folks are kind of moving
out to the beach as they as they get
tired of the city life ok so so that's
interesting so now we've given these
retail site selectors the tools to go
ahead and look at you know different
areas and see what the demographics are
you know to be honest if codes are
pretty coarse-grained geometry for this
analysis you'd rather use census tracts
or census blocks again you can get those
from the American Community Survey page
like go to the one go to the download
tab that's where you can download like
you know census tracts or zip codes for
the entire United States and bring that
into bigquery we're going to look at
this last query here because this kind
of the summary table so same kind of
same kind of construction so width and
stats by zip code this is actually the
same code as before and what we're going
to do here is we're going to run those
stats for a collection of radii so we're
going to create a summary table like
show me the list of people that live one
10 20 50 miles from my from my chosen
location and again we're using the
bigquery GIS functions to construct that
filter
all right and then here's the resulting
table and now what we're gonna this is
not GIS but it is super convenient you
look at this button here called
exploring data studio you can actually
click on that and that will materialize
the results in a data studio session
let's go ahead so let's see the
dimension we're going to use is R so
that's the radius we'll get rid of that
one and then well let's see we'll do
population well Chad is pulling in these
different demographic groups as well to
davis newt is something we just launched
into GA last week which is super
exciting in this particular
functionality that the integration
between bigquery and data studio without
one-click UI experience is something
that we launched earlier this summer at
at our cloud next event and that's been
one of it's been a very popular feature
our customers been asking about it it
was really nice to be able to deliver
that and people have been responding
real well to that it's been fun
excellent it's just super quick for you
know just like we had the big crazy of
is application to be able to quickly
explore your geospatial data you can do
the same thing here with with summary
tables with other data to quickly
visualize it into the studio yeah and so
with just a few clicks and a little bit
of you know clumsy dragging of these
little tickets you can create a chart
you can then save it copy it to a report
and share it with folks and they can
interact you know with your query as
well so anyway we wanted to we wanted to
get that one out we've got one more demo
to talk about which is actually a
totally different persona so now like
we're done with being reject real estate
moguls or or retail moguls we're now
we're city planners from Chicago and so
our customer geotab actually built this
application and so what you're seeing
here is a map of hazardous driving
behavior and you might naturally ask
yourself the question well how does
geotab know anything about hazardous
driving application great question
thanks for asking geotab is an asset
tracking company and a telematics
company and so for example FedEx enough
FedEx UPS all the UPS trucks have a box
about yay big in their truck and that
box measures location velocity
acceleration plus a host of other
barriers exactly so geotab actually has
an incredibly rich dataset collected by
one point
two million vehicles running around the
country I think their data set their
daily intake is about three billion
points all of that gets stored inside of
bigquery which you'll find out soon is a
very convenient place to do it so what
the map shows here is areas in Chicago
that register hazardous driving behavior
and that's characterized by extreme
amounts of acceleration either forward
and back or lateral and what this left
panel is going to do is we're actually
going to combine a few different
technologies here in just a few clicks
so we have bigquery GIS which is going
to call out the points from Chicago we
have obviously Google Maps and we have
bigquery ml which is going to actually
they've actually trained a model to
predict hazardous driving behavior ie
those accelerations based on weather
data now the next question is like
where'd you get the weather data another
excellent question he's awesome the NOAA
actually hosts weather data in bigquery
and so joining your data with weather
data is literally only a joint away
because it's all hosted in the same
back-end storage all right so here
that's enough context setting let's get
to it so we're gonna dial up some
weather conditions so I'm reducing the
temperature so we're gonna make it
winter reduce the visibility I'm gonna
order a snowstorm and then we're gonna
pretend it's the holiday season and
we're gonna bump up the traffic volume
and then I just clicked run predictive
analysis and we get a map that's a lot
hotter than the original one okay that's
interesting so that's no no colder
because it's winter it's hotter in terms
of hazardous driving I totally get you
any case we're gonna we're gonna look in
at one of these because as a traffic
planner for the city of Chicago like we
want to investigate these points and see
what we can do and in particular there's
one that we're gonna dive into right
here because here it is because it is
just down the street from a school so
being elected officials right we're
gonna prioritize safety of constituents
we're gonna prioritize safety of
vulnerable constituents focus on
hazardous driving around schools
through the network of streets bro yeah
we just we want to keep our kids safe
all right so what's going on here so
it's interesting that there's hazardous
driving behavior in inclement weather
but what's going on so this is where we
get a little bit of a benefit from being
in the Google ecosystem and we're going
to drop the street view avatar into the
scene and so we're going to turn around
so here's the school and then I'm gonna
move just a little bit east and look at
what's here so I'll make this screen a
bit bigger for you and we'll zoom in
just a touch it's a bike rack there you
go
right next to an alleyway so you know I
agreed I dealt up a winter day but maybe
some kids are riding their bike down
this alleyway and causing some kind of
traffic congestion or traffic issue here
let's spin around and see what's going
on I don't see any traffic signage right
so just down here at the end of this
picture is where that hazardous driving
behavior was occurring but there's no
traffic signage here you know maybe the
right remediation is to pre position
some sand maybe the right remediation is
to put a stop sign in here even
crosswalk yeah or crosswalk yeah good
point
but what we what we what we've enabled
here is our city planner can now scan
the entire city using GIS ml bigquery
Google Maps Street View public data all
without leaving their chair and that is
pretty darn cool oh here take it out of
the full screen mode all right
anyway so thank you for going on that
little that little journey so we did
that demo we just finished this one I
skipped ahead in the slides a little bit
and yeah so this is obviously amazing
things that you can do using this
functionality tons more resources we
wanted to arm you with first of all if
you want to get started in bigquery you
can just go right to the cloud console
that's the first link there that
particular bigquery G of is application
for just you know visualizing your
sequel queries on that map is the is the
there's the link there for you as well
tons of documentation very thorough all
the the phone
that I went through those are all
detailed out one by one in the
documentation which is really helpful
and also have a link for all those
public datasets that we host in bigquery
that's in our GCP marketplace you can
also of course go find any any of the
open datasets out there and bring them
in to your particular projects as well
and then too we have a stack overflow
topic here on Google bigquery with with
the GIS particular tag and this is where
we'll post a Chad will post all these
queries sometime in the next few days
yep so that you can play around with
those again you saw how the facility of
just putting in a lot long pair for that
center point of your retail ring study
but you could conceivably do that at any
location yeah you might want to explore
let me speak specifically if there are
people watching who are either in retail
or in like television or radio ratings
then like these queries are very readily
extensible to census tracts census
blocks or DMAs
so like we didn't we didn't go to that
extent because you know we just wanted
to keep things simple here but if that's
your industry then use those as your
template and you can do these analyses
and show them on the bigger AG of this
great Thanks
well that's what we had to show for
today thank you chad for walking through
those demos those are super cool and and
folks everybody stay tuned for live Q&A
we'll be back in just a couple minutes
to cover those thank you
you
great welcome back everybody so we're
here now for the live Q&A portion of our
webinar and we got several great
questions from the audience so we'll
just kind of dive into those and and do
it one more time so first off I have a
few answers shapefiles i'd like to use
super super common can I use them with
big crazy is the answer is yes although
you would need to convert that shapefile
format into either well no text or some
of the other formats that we can then
bring in right yeah we got this question
a lot right right after we launched the
Alpha and so we actually have and we'll
put it up in the stack overflow topic we
actually have a document that one of our
colleagues wrote that details exactly
how to do like you know what's the right
tool to use and how do you bring it in
but you know essentially Soleil is right
you have to convert the shape file into
the format's that we support and then
you can look at them just like we did in
the demos an exocrine does bigquery GS
have geocoding capabilities yeah so we
rely on the Google Maps API s for this
so bigquery bigquery itself does not but
you can like in a different part of your
program you can like call an API and
augment you know augment the table that
you're looking at with the geo coded
data or you can you can call any
external API as part of a dataflow job
so you can like read out a bigquery
column through a dataflow job then call
that API augment the data and then write
that back into bigquery
I see great for visualizations and
mapping what other BI tools can i
connect the quarry to so bigquery has I
mean a number of you know native
connections to two different BI tools
like tableau and looker and click and
things like this specifically for
mapping and connecting to you know your
bigquery GIS functions so long as those
tools support custom sequel queries and
so long as they can render Geographic
data types they should be able to to
leverage this technology and one thing
as well as probably want to bring that
into a geo JSON format right to do that
yeah so tableau is an example of
of a vis tool that you'll want to use
the custom queries to to leverage
bigquery GIS and then looker actually
looker actually supports the query GIS
well next question does a bit crazy I
support 3d geometries and measure values
X Y M or X Y Z M I'll let you take that
oh I actually don't know the answer to
this one
the answer is no we don't support the
thanks for that one hey these are these
are questions that people are having
yeah what this does bigquery GS come
with geospatial statistical data for
instance parcel map data that I can use
to join with my business data oh that's
a great question
so not really so bigquery is so big
query GIS comes with bigquery bigquery
comes with Google cloud platform and
inside Google cloud platform are a whole
host of public datasets and we went
through some of these or I showed you a
very small subset of the list if there
are some public data sets that have some
of that geospatial statistical data that
you want like I do happen to know that
zip code land and water areas are there
things like that you might be able to
find them in the public data sets if not
then you're going to have to import them
using this using the procedure that
we'll publish in that Stack Overflow
topic next question looks like we've
already addressed with respect to
geocoding for a final question there for
non-programmers working with large
amounts of data is there a resource for
query language to facilitate pulling or
geo-locating data so I would just for
this if you're not a programmer I would
just direct your attention to the
bigquery documentation for GIS there are
a ton of resources there again it's all
fully outlined all of the different
functions that are there there are
several tutorials as well we'll post
some links to the Stack Overflow there
as well and yeah that's that yeah yeah I
do definitely so like as we all know
right we work with geospatial data and
for those that have know that there are
data sets like all over the place and in
all sorts of different formats
and there's like aside from shapefiles
like which is I suppose a bit of an
industry center but there's just like
gdb MDB there's a whole lot of stuff out
there we don't have a sequel verb that
says like go get this data set and bring
it in however it's a really good idea
and we've already written it down but
what you will have to do is if you've
got you know if you're a non programmer
have a look at the resources again this
article about pulling in other types of
data other types of data formats into
bigquery and then the process to the
process to copy that over requires a
couple lines of code but you can
literally copy and paste from the
article and put that into the console in
the directions there are clear enough
that even I was able to get it right on
the very first time I was not the author
- so I was actually testing great well
thanks everybody that concludes our Q&A
portion do stay tuned we have another
webinar following this one it's called
visualized 2030 this is about a data
storytelling contest that Google cloud
is hosting around the UN sustainable
development goals and that will be
coming up in just a few moments live
from New York City
thanks again everybody oh absolutely i'm
chad and happy mapping